pirate fest returned to craig ranch park  in north las vegas today yes you heard  me pirate fest  organizers say they are happy get it to  have  everyone back after a year of lockdowns  there was food  music live entertainment games and of  course  pirates they had a great turnout with  people coming from all over the valley  and even from some other states the  private camaraderie we have  it is a brotherhood it's people that get  together from all walks of life  you know different occupations you name  it i myself with my social worker i've  been doing it for 28 years  we have people in law enforcement we  have firemen we have a little bit of  everything  but we all share that particular common  goal of having  great time as pirates pretty great right  if you want to check it out it's also  open tomorrow from 11am to 7pm  tickets 15 bucks for adults 10 for kids